I will tell you what what was the span
of reactions yes yes so I yes yes good
so let's go this thought about the good
people the good side
my host friend john khan said to me
Danny this yellow is trying to tell us
something and I challenge you to find
out what it is this was the good
direction bad reaction
well that my group leader came to my
office one day this was in the first
month that I was talking about his
material and a smiling sheepishly he put
a x-ray diffraction book on my desk and
said that something like Danny please
read this book and so you understand
that what you are saying cannot be and
this is because the picture you had
seemed to defy all the possibilities
that were allowed under crystallography
in those day that is correct
but it's not it was not one picture it
was a series of long series of
experiments the famous diffraction
picture is one of very many experiments
all done by electron microscopy
transmission electron microscopy so he
he gave me the book in said please read
I said you know I know this book I'm a
teacher and attorney all I teach these
things and I don't need to read it I'm
telling you this is something different
it's not in the book so he took the book
and some time later now I don't remember
how many days or how many hours it was
but he came back and said Danny you're a
disgrace to my group and I wanted to
leave my goal to be associated beliefs
so I moved to another group now this
didn't mean much it sounds something
traumatic but this is was not I just had
to find another group leader who will
adopt me you know the often to
scientific often we will adopt me and
somebody did and all it meant was that
instead of reporting to this secretary
- that secretary I didn't move for my
office all for my laboratory I did it it
was just about the same it was not very
dramatic now when people hear about all
of you thrown away from here oh yeah but
it was not for me at least it was no
traumatic it was not now I said I didn't
feel very good about it but yeah so this
was the span of reaction between
encouragement and and rejection and
everything was somewhere in between text